[Music]
thank you Thank You Hanna thanks to all
of you for coming the subject before us
tonight Trump an American tragedy and
our speakers are divided between those
who think that should come with a
question mark at the end and those who
think a full stop will do just fine
and we have all those views represented
tonight I'm going to get straight on
onto it and by introducing our panel I'm
just going to tell you a word though
about how we're going to do it we're
going to have a conversation up here and
with our guests joining us via video for
the first powerful so and then we are
going to open it up and take clusters or
questions from all of you and bring them
back to our panel here so I'm hoping
it's very much a two-way conversation if
it lurches into group therapy then
you'll correct me I'm sure so let's get
on with introducing our very stellar
line-up of speakers all of whom are
highly qualified to talk about this
subject and come at it from different
angles so let me begin by introducing on
the my far-right the Pulitzer Prize
winning historian and regular foreign
policy columnist for The Washington Post
Anne Applebaum
you'll know him as a regular commentator
on US politics and on world affairs he
served the I was going to say the first
President Clinton turned out to be the
only President Clinton as Assistant
Secretary of State for public affairs he
was an advisor to the current Clinton
campaign he is Jamie Rubin
on my immediate right here is the former
vice chairman of Republicans abroad and
chair of American Voices international
she also worked in the White House under
President George W Bush as well as on
the first gubernatorial campaign of Mitt
Romney in Massachusetts whatever
happened to him she is a warm welcome
please for Stacy Hilliard he may be back
there saying over here we'll get into
that on my immediate left a weekly
columnist for the independent a regular
contributor to my own paper The Guardian
an expert writer on foreign affairs and
diplomacy married to Jeff's key and
completing our lineup in the flesh as it
were is the CEO of the Roosevelt Group
who served on the Executive Board of the
World Economic Forum but crucially for
our purposes he has been tipped in a few
places for a role in the incoming
administration of Donald Trump so I'm
sure you're going to want to welcome Ted
malar and I'm going to say introduce our
two guests so joining us by video and I
don't if we're able to see them straight
away but the first of those is a
professor at Columbia University one of
America's leading experts on
constitutional law a lifelong Democrat
who's actually served administration's
of both parties and written extensively
he is philip Bobbitt are you seeing him
I think you are
welcome to Philip and also coming in and
out of view depending is the former
director of strategy for Prime Minister
David Cameron co-founder and CEO of
crowd Peck a Silicon Valley political
tech startup teachers at Stanford and is
the only person I think here can claim
to have inspired his own character on
the thick of it he is Steve Hilton may
have a few glitches with Philip that
will come to him when that's all cleared
up so let's get straight on with it and
the opening area I want to get into is
really we're going to look forward and
we're going to focus on what next but we
we thought it was a good idea to do it
just a little bit of explanation of what
just happened on November the 8th what
are at least a few of our panelists
think explains this result which I think
it's fair to say not to many people in
any field not just mine saw coming and
so why don't we just hear a sort of an
opening thesis from you Stacy Hilliard
on what you think explains this pretty
well unexpected victory for Donald Trump
on November the 8th well I'm not sure
but so it was an unexpected victory I
think a lot of people anticipated this
I'm did you pretty I did Siddiq tit and
you can ask my partner I went a hundred
pounds off of him because I should have
tweeted but I'm I think one of the big
reasons that this happened is because
Hillary Clinton was the candidate and I
think she was very much a flawed
candidate she was very much the
presumptive incumbent in a year that was
not a year to be an incumbent her
message was very much a he had Obama
let's have it again Obama Mach 2 and
that message didn't resonate with people
who hadn't had the recovery that they
were expecting since 2008 so people were
still found $4000 worse off than they
were before the Great Recession happened
people were frustrated they didn't see
that they had benefited from any of the
recovery and I think that was that
economic message at Donald Trump but
said I'm going to create jobs is what
push them forward and is it your view
that in a way that was always true and
baked in early on and actually all the
ups and downs of the campaign it was a
very dramatic campaign
in in September October November the
debates the revelations the tapes in a
way none of that made a difference the
mind was made up because this was a
change year it was definitely a changer
and I think you saw that with the
support that Bernie Sanders had and
particularly the sport he had from
Millennials and and Hillary wasn't able
with particularly with millennial women
she wasn't able to get that support that
they expected and they were really
looking at what are the policies and
they were voting on policies and they're
saying I want to be able to pay my
student loans off I want to be able to
get a job I want to be able to advance
myself and they weren't seeing that
being possible under her so that's the
perspective of a Republican who
defensely was not a Donald Trump
supporter and early on in the process
what about you Ted Mallik well you know
we heard the theory there that in a way
it's mainly about the deficiencies of
Hillary Clinton is that your explanation
for why Donald Trump won well it's
certainly one of the reasons I think I
take issue it the first with the title
of this whole debate calling it a
tragedy we've got a question mark in
there well I don't think it's a question
mark I don't think in a Shakespearean
year either is it a comedy I think what
Trump will prove that this is very much
a Republican play the pendulum has swung
I mean this is a pendulum year and its
really an election of realignment so
we've moved from a blue country to a red
country except on the coast and I think
that the social science term to explain
all this
Bronstein and others have used it as
class inversion so we have as a white
middle class that has been largely
excluded as a result of globalization
and globalism from participation in the
economy and they basically said like in
the movie or mad as hell and we're not
going to take it anymore but I'm
professor Bobby it's great to have you I
didn't know how much you heard what was
said before I've just come in good I'm
going to see you easy assume nothing and
we're looking for an explanation for
this election which not many some but
not many hold right in advance we've
talked about the perceived deficiencies
of Hillary Clinton and maybe that was
part of it and then we've also heard it
just it was a change year and in a
change here the pendulum was going to
swing away from Democrats
towards Republicans what is your own
explanation for why this outcome came
about
we're certainly true that all political
societies have more values than they can
realize and so they bring to temporary
preeminence one party that after for
eight years they shift gears and
bringing on another party to support
different values there's a pattern of
that that's partly I think an
explanation but I think the broader
picture is that this is the change
happening all across the industrial and
post-industrial societies it is a change
as the kind of state we have had in the
US since the 1860s and Europe since the
1870s has begun to very rapidly decay
with the end of the long wars the 20th
century and the reaction of groups that
were linked to that state industrial
groups national groups because each of
these industrial nation states favored a
particular sort of ethnic and political
group that reaction is playing out all
across the democracies I want to put
this to you then Steve Hilton if you can
hear us yeah
this is this idea that there was a
common pattern here brexit then Trump
the phrase use now perhaps overused
about those who are left behind and that
this is really about some of those
bigger forces that Philip Bobbitt was
perhaps describing and a response to
globalization etc just sketch out for us
if you think that is what was going on
in this election I think I think that's
certainly a big part of it but it's not
the only thing I think that really I
think we've been support to look at the
election not just in I know that the
theme of most of our discussions would
be Trump but I think it's important to
look at it in the context of the whole
election because of course the
Republicans won not just the presidency
but the Senate and the House and state
legislatures across the country and
governor's races it was a really big
defeat for Democrats in general not just
Hillary Clinton and I think that what
that tells you is that this was a
repudiation a big repudiation of the
Obama years and I think in
in two particular ways and the first is
actually beyond just Obama and that's
where I agree about this general point
on globalization I think the economic
explanation is pretty fundamental for me
the most telling statistic the most
telling data point that explains more
than anything else about what happened
is Stacey touched on this earlier is
that despite incomes in America happily
increasing in the last 12 months that
that that came out during the campaign
and in about September if you look at
the long-run picture the median
household income in the America today is
lower than it was in 1999 I think that
has two aspects to it first of all the
straightforward economic part which is
the people now that's half of America
half of American households earning less
than then before Bush began his
presidency and Obama so they've had
eight years of Bush eight years of Obama
and throughout all of that incomes of
doubt while the rich have got richer and
I think that explains not just that
sensitive economic frustration of the
political frustration - because the
sense is that it doesn't matter who you
vote for doesn't matter whether you have
Republicans at the White House or
Democrats you know literally the rich
get richer we get poor and so that's
what I think explains that sense of
desperation it says look we can a vote
for Trump despite all his obvious flaws
as an individual and as a candidate and
so on because they're just looking for
something that will change it but I do
think there's one other aspect of this
that I think it's important to bear in
mind and I think this is probably
particularly a u.s. aspect rather than
the global one and that is this very
strong sense I think on the part of a
lot of people of being really not just
left behind economically but but really
condescended to and spoken down to by
the people they receive to be running
the economy and running government and I
think the moment that really
crystallized that I thought was the
moment when I thought that Hillary
Clinton was bound to lose was her speech
about the basket of deplorable where she
really revealed the attitude that I
think a lot of people in in the
heartland of America working people
sense that they are viewed by the
coastal elites as being
area not culturally up to the mark and
so on and I think that that cultural
aspect of it was really important to
live with that well that goes nicely to
Anne Applebaum because you've written
some some things in these areas and
talked about this that it isn't just
about economics there's a cultural
dimension to this yeah I mean it's
something as big as an election like
this it's very hard to pinpoint exactly
why everybody voted for what reason
there are many reasons but I think a lot
of the economic explanations have been
pretty superficial if you look at how
the voting went you know actually the
poorest Americans and this is all across
including in for example in Texas which
is a red state the poorest Americans
voted for Hillary Clinton so we're not
talking about exactly it's not like the
poor rose up and overthrew the rich it's
a much more complicated problem I also
think that there's not enough attention
had been paid to how Trump ran his
campaign and the language that he was
using to attract people he really he
also created a kind of us in them very
much like authoritarian leaders do we
the real Americans against the fake
Americans and he created a sense of
identity around a group that hadn't I
mean I suppose it's been appealed to
like that before but not in quiet clear
not quite as aggressive away and he
appealed to them almost as if he were a
in the way that say you know a European
nationalist appeals to his own nation
you know you know the Dutch to Dutch
people you know we need to be more Dutch
and this was really a very make America
great again has an element of nostalgia
to it as well you know that it's a kind
of bringing back the real America and I
think that at a time when politics are
incredibly seem very distant from people
and they seem very you know in a world
where you can do all kinds of things
very quickly you know you can order
something online and click a button and
get delivered the next day and you can
like something and feel like you've made
a statement politics seems very
complicated it takes a long time
democracy is very boring it's very
frustrating and Trump seemed to offer
some kind of instant solutions in a very
classic populist sort of magical
thinking I will fix it I will make
things great again and he appealed to
the cultural identity
of a part of it and I think that was
part of what he just just take further
the point you made about European
populist figures some people have said
in response to the kind of argument
Steve Hilton was making about economics
they've said don't underestimate the
extent to which this was a nativist
appeal loaded with with racial
resentment because he was saying and
people said make America great again
means make America white again and there
was this element of God gender it was a
female candidate and people have said
that you know that you can't you cannot
exclude that from the picture just just
what racism is very much don't want to
say that everybody who voted for Trump
is a racist I'm not saying that but I
think there was an element of you know
we've had this black president we have
this woman can you know let's have one
of us again
you know let's bring back somebody who
is familiar somebody who belongs in the
familiar hierarchy let's get back to
where we were before and to a lot of
people that had a subconscious or
conscious appeal and by the way you
could see it you know if he didn't say
it exactly you could absolutely see it
on social media I mean the the racism
the anti-semitism and the misogyny of
his supporters was something I have
never seen before in American politics
ever and there was a lot of it and it
was all the time and everybody who who
interacted it all online saw it and so
that can't be eliminated as an issue
today we should let you have a response
just on that point so there is an old
left as well as an altar right and the
political spectrum is a very wide
spectrum it is in the United States is
in European countries I think that Trump
is really very much a center-right
politician not a far-right politician
but he means what would he have -
already bringing people into his
administration what would you have to do
for you to describe him as far
he'd have to prove that he was an
authority in terms of actions rather
than jerk exactly
like we're going to get back into all
this I'm sure but Jamie let's go to you
on on what now in a way we've we talked
up to night November the 8th November
the 8th to November 30th we've had 22
days of him being president-elect Trump
what have we seen what have we learned
what little clues have we got into
Wallace let me thank you for excusing me
from the explanation part of the
discussion because it would be too
painful um look there's a couple of
things that I think you can see already
in the domestic area we have seen the
president-elect suggest in a meeting
with the New York Times that maybe his
actions on Obamacare won't be so drastic
and then higher as the or proposed as
the Secretary of Health and Human
Services the single most opponent of
Obamacare so I think we're seeing that
going back and forth and we'll just have
to see how that comes about I tend to do
foreign policy I'll stick with that
except I can't help but throw in that
that it looks like Donald Trump will be
the least rich member of his cabinet
because he's hired only billionaires for
the domestic area and that's not a
comment about what his real wealth is
it's just a comment about how rich these
who are working for a dollar by the way
right they don't need the money you're
absolutely right the on foreign affairs
where I actually know some of the
individuals involved I don't know
whether you call it all tried or extreme
right or way on the right it would be
hard to find two more extreme right-wing
people who will spend the most time all
day long with Donald Trump particularly
the National Security Advisor Miss
General Flynn who holds views that were
deemed so unusual by the military and
the intelligence community that he was
essentially pushed out of his job it
ended up being called a management issue
when he was the director
the Defense Intelligence Agency but
basically he was so out of sync with the
mainstream of the national security
bureaucracy it's not the Obama Obama let
me just have my speak and you can please
jump in we're talking about an Obama
administration where the national
security bureaucracy not the president
the national security bureaucracy asked
him to go but President had nothing to
do with this these were generals these
were the heads of the the national
intelligence community thought general
Flynn was just too aggressive they had
things called Flynn facts which were
wild unusual things today's New York
Times gives you an example of where
general Flynn believes not only the one
you've heard that radical Islam is a is
is the explanation Islam is more of an
explanation than the radicalization of
youth that's the way he would put it and
you know he's entitled to that view but
he's regarded George Bush as having not
sufficiently focused on Islam this is
general Flynn regards former President
Bush as missing the point when he went
to a mosque and tried to say that Islam
is not the problem it's a small
percentage that's not Obama that's
President Bush that he regarded as as
insufficiently anti Islamic for him but
the real kicker came out today which is
that general Flynn believes and I am not
exaggerating that the radical Islamic
groups like al Qaeda and others are
linked up with China and North Korea and
that there is an axis of China North
Korea and radical Islam that poses a
threat to the United States if you don't
believe me please look at today's New
York Times there's a very clear
description of what's in his book and I
urge you to read it if you think I'm
exaggerating so all I would say is that
there it's very hard to know what
Trump's foreign policy is going to be
the only thread that holds it together
the only one I can see is a extreme
approach to the terrorists
counterterrorism problem by focusing
more on the religion than the Obama and
Bush administration which I did
and roughly the same on the
counterterrorism classic approach we
thank you we're certainly going to talk
about foreign policy more and we're
going to move on to that just in terms
of these 22 days what they revealed the
manner the style the way the
appointments are being a very very very
brief very primary this is easy it's a
very unusual time in our lives when the
president United States goes on his
tweeter or Twitter or whatever I'm not
very good at this and says that millions
of people were fraudulently voted which
is a lie and then when CNN and and see
if you can remember the last time this
happened says that these claims are
baseless he tweets back you prove it's
not true when's the last time we heard
that Ted you want to come back on that
very good one then we're gonna get to
Mary okay what why don't you just come
back just on this point about the tweet
about the million chunk claiming the
millions vote to 40 let me focus on that
the source is Clinton news network as we
call it in the United States which is a
total collaboration with the Democratic
Party so who's to know what to believe
I mean the fact is and we'll see this
more and more evidence when you know
they're not the research is done but in
when the empirical evidence is brought
forward that a lot of illegal immigrants
voted in this election because they
couldn't prove that they're the right to
vote or not to vote I mean it's an
ongoing problem in American politics
taystee just because you're there are
you comfortable with this kind of talk
you you've been pretty supportive in
your public comments of the Trump
election hearing these claims millions
of fraudulent voters I'm not and I have
a slightly different tape to Jaime which
is I don't really take it seriously I
think that fundamentally we've over the
last 18 months I think we've all
understood that that there are aspects
of Trump's behavior that no one could
support including his supporters that's
not why they voted faith and so I I'm
not at all surprised that some aspects
of that
continuing even though others are
clearly being moderated and for me I'm
long past the point of being outraged by
or shocked or surprised when he does of
that kind and I think the real question
is will he deliver on the core promises
he made particularly of getting growth
up bringing jobs back raising people's
incomes in the end that's what he's got
to do and all this other stuff I think
is you know maybe unattractive it may be
disrespectful to the Constitution and so
on but in the end I think you know we've
passed the point of looting clarity that
means because what I'm the sense I'm
getting from a couple of colleagues here
is it was fine to not take him seriously
when he wasn't the president-elect of
the United States that's the boy he's
now the president he's now about to be
the president so don't you have to start
taking it seriously know what you have
to take seriously is the problem the
real-world problems that he's going to
have to deal with which is falling
incomes low labor participation rates a
terror threat all these are real things
and the right way to judge him is how he
handles those real things okay not
whether he's tweeting and having been
exchanged with CNN okay let me have her
duet from Merida Jessie and I want to
bring you in just on these other things
we heard spiritedly from Jamie about the
one particular foreign policy
appointment the lots has happened
Twitter and others just the process just
what like can you shed on that well I
think there's been an enormous amount of
criticism especially in Europe I mean I
think Europe still has not got Donald
Trump and it probably won't maybe for a
year maybe for eight years we could be
looking at it we just do not get it and
we didn't get it through the campaign
which is why we actually got it more
wrong than even Americans got it and I
agree a lot with what Steve has said and
I think we've got to get used to the
idea this is the president who maybe we
may be looking at the future shape of
the American presidency not in terms of
Donald Trump's idiosyncrasies but in
terms of a president who speaks direct
to the people who uses the social media
who answers back who does all sorts of
things that use not to be at all
acceptable
I mean in the future these things may
become the norm second thing I'd like to
say is that looking at the transition
from over here there's been enormous
amounts of criticism saying oh my
goodness isn't this chaotic oh he
doesn't know what he's doing he doesn't
know who to appoint and all the rest of
it
he started incredibly early the United
States has a long transition this is a
luxury compared especially what the
United Kingdom has in terms of forming
governments and putting people in power
he has the luxury he has until January
to get his main post sorted out I don't
think that what we've been looking at it
chaos it's been quite a sensible system
of interviewing people for the top jobs
which doesn't seem to me to be chaotic
or anarchic that's how it's the other
thing you did when he tweeted saying
I've now worked out who the finalists
are only I know they are as if you know
tune in to tomorrow night's apprentice
to find out well I'm waiting for British
television to show the American
Apprentice series in retrospect so that
we can see a bit more about what this
president looks like and how he behaves
but I think that's a quirk of language
that's a quirk of manner I don't think
this that this sort of cheapens the
presidency good let's move into now
imagine it's January the 20th he will be
inaugurated and look ahead to what kind
of policy agenda he will pursue him
we're going to divide this into the
domestic area and the foreign policy
area and Stacy Hilliard why didn't you
kick Singh off with what you think he
might do what you think he should do and
I know those are different questions but
what he's what is domestic agenda is
likely to consist of well what he should
do and what he might do is he needs to
do something that's a bit of a quick win
for him something that he can not only
just get through the House and the
Senate but also get a bit of bipartisan
support and one of the things that
they're talking a lot about with that is
the infrastructure bill rebuilding our
bridges and our roads which is something
that is desperately needed we've heard
that with multiple presidents over the
past several cycles and we haven't
really seen that I'm so that's one of
the ways that he's looking at actually
growing some jobs and putting some money
back into the economy
I think one of the other things that he
can do that he's talked about doing a
lot of pundits have spoken about is some
tax reform and I think that's something
that can happen quite quickly flattening
the tax code our tax code is incredibly
complicated and trying to find a way
that we can reduce the number of income
tax brackets so that's one thing that
they're looking at but then the big
thing that everybody talks about in
Jamie touched on this already is
Obamacare and in the past should her
repeal and replace
now they're saying repeal and transition
and what they're talking about with that
is saying well maybe what we'll do is
we'll give it a time a timeline we'll
put an expiry date on it that at that
time then it falls off the cliff and so
maybe that will force those in the
Senate and to be able to actually put
together a package that we pass they're
not sure where they want to trigger
article 50 when it comes to Obamacare
fill it Bobby why don't we just come to
you if you're if you're still able to
hear us I'm just struck by this point
about infrastructure spending and roads
and highways and bridges if it if it
it's there if he's not open to one of
our other speakers but the idea that
this would be a big part of Trump's
agenda and I'm just tempted to say that
would have been a big part of what a
president Hillary Clinton would have
wanted to do to and therefore will
Democrats in Congress actually end up
giving the green light to that because
it's something they would have wanted to
do anyway if Philip Robbins there will
hear from you if not we'll put it to one
of the others who are here till I take
that if he's not he's eager if you're
not there filippov it will tip we'll put
it to Steve but then we get the crucial
briefing though because we've got people
here if you want to think that yeah yeah
will receive free feeling will come to
church yeah I do very quick response I
think that the crucial difference in how
they might how President Clinton would
have approached it and how Trump is
likely to approach it is lies in the
funding of it and that's where you might
get a disagreement even though the aim
of investing in infrastructure might be
shared I think the Democratic
approaching Clinton approach would have
relied more on public spending as the
source of the financing whereas Trump's
approach in my view correctly would
identify the source of funding as coming
from the private sector from pension
funds and so on and
therefore the revenue that comes from
the infrastructure for example in the
form of tolls being a crucial part of
the mix not just straightforward okay
how big spending to pay for it Jamie so
that's one difference well I I'm going
to agree with you except for the part
you didn't say who would pay the tolls I
happen to have been a commissioner of
the Port Authority in New York one of
these weird jobs that I had very briefly
and what I learned is there's plenty of
cash to and and money to build
infrastructure in the United States
there's trillions of available dollars
the problem is no politician wants to
ask the people to pay tolls to fund the
infrastructure so in France you drive
down a road and it's beautiful and then
you pay eight dollars and 70 cents after
going three miles in the United States
they don't want to ask for tolls so it's
nice that there are suggestions that
these private financing will be
available I'm interested to see who the
politicians are we're going to ask for
the tolls but what you didn't hear is
that the original bill by Donald Trump
as I understand it was more about tax
cuts for programs that were already
planned that it was essentially to take
existing infrastructure plans and give a
tax break to the people who were going
to build it rather than building more
than was planned which I agree with you
would have come from public funds and
that's what the Democrats want to do but
my guess is they will go along they
don't really have much power yet and
they kind of have to go along because
they Republicans control the house and
the Senate and it won't take much in the
Senate to get a few senators to go along
with an infrastructure of Intan had come
forward with these proposals Congress
republican-controlled Congress would
have howled and said this is profligate
fiscal spending it's fiscally
incontinent of course you got it and the
same package of proposals will be put to
the by Donald Trump and will say this is
wonderful this is going to make America
great again there won't be the same
proposals Steve has outlined the entire
infrastructure packages will be a
trillion dollar package will be largely
private funding
and that is being toyed with right now
by people who'll be going into Treasury
secretary it'll be an altogether
different proposal but Chuck Schumer has
already come out and said he's the
tetrahedron he's a democratically during
the Senate he's from New York and he's
worked with Trump before he's already
come out and said let's get something
done we need this let's prime the
economy we can go on this I think it's a
given one big obvious difference
infrastructure project is the wall that
he promises to build
he always said Mexico was going to pay
for it I tend to say how's that working
out but just tell us about the image
that as an infrastructure project is he
is he serious that I think he's deadly
serious about it I think there'll be a
shovel in the ground what you might not
realize is there's already a wall in
Southern California that extends for
many many many many miles and it will be
extended the entire thing will not be a
physical wall I wrote about this at
length and I think part of the wall be
electronic part of the wall might indeed
be a fence but there will be an
infrastructure project on the wall with
our southern border because you can't
have a country that doesn't respect its
own national sovereignty Stacey just
want to come in on the wall point well
I've actually kind of said all along
that you know he's not going to build
this actual wall across the the entire
you think you support is a voter from
knew that well I'm from Texas and I
think we knew that you're not going to
build a wall we have a nice beautiful
river as a natural border there and it's
and I think that people see that that is
actually addressing the issue of the
pressures that illegal immigration put
on and coming from a border state we see
that all the time the pressures it puts
on on the border towns how it decimates
education systems the health care
systems and that has to be funded by
somebody and it has to be tax dollars
and it's usually from the states that
that's being funded and it's causing a
lot of problems and that when we have
the immigration debate we have two
debates we have an illegal immigration
debate and a legal debate and I think
that people often mix the two and assume
that is if we're talking about
immigration then we don't want people
coming over and actually taking any job
such as in high-tech or if they're
programmers and as opposed to the
illegal an immigration debate which i
think is something that
other people and I want to bring you in
and put one question I know you've got
something you want to yourself but one
thing I want to ask is you know Ted
mallet referred to Chuck Schumer the
Democrat who's tempted to say okay let's
do something here and I'm just wondering
whether you think Democrats should do
that thereby handing Donald Trump a
tangible victory that he can say look
I've achieved things or should they take
a leaf out of the Republican book in
2010 2011 when they Republicans said
we're just not going to give this guy
anything Obama we're going to sabotage
it so first of all don't ask me I'm not
a registered I know you know I'm usually
what your analytical view of that
question is no so I mean I think it's
very interesting absolutely one of the
ideas after 2008 that Obama had was
let's do a big huge infrastructure
investment green green technology
rebuild the trains let's do a whole life
and he was blocked again and again and
again and again by Republican congresses
so for me it's just ironic that that now
Trump wants to do exactly the same thing
and I don't really have a view about
what Democrats should do I think they
should you know make their decision
based on what the law says and and and
how affected they think was going to be
I just wanted to say something that the
wall I think the wall was to refer to
what I was saying earlier I don't think
the wall matters whether the wall is
real or not the wall was a was a
metaphor you know the wall was let's
keep people out you know let's make
America great again let's protect what
we have it was an image that appealed to
crowds remember he would shout build the
wall build the wall people would applaud
and I don't think it really make you
know as you say something like a third
of the border is already covered by
either a wall or a fence and actually
the illegal immigration problem in the
United States is not really about people
crossing the border it's more about
people flying in and overstaying visas
that's actually the main source of
illegal immigration so the wall is a
kind of it's a completely phony it's not
a real problem it's a phony it's a it's
an image it's a thing we need to we need
to conjure up you know to help create
this this kind of tribal identity this
yeah I didn't you Hampshire any no
higher and they didn't think he was
promising to build a big beautiful
metaphor they thought he was building a
wall and that's what they will no I I
mean okay but but why were they
applauding it I mean particularly people
in New Hampshire why do people in New
Hampshire care about the wall
they're in really it's really you know
they should be worried about Canada you
know that's the real threat I mean jjg
want to coming just quick down this Jim
the war know let's get on to it was a
good song there is a good let's get on
to foreign policy and we were rattling
through here but let's talk about
because there's a lot there to say
there's a specific argument to have to
be had and we're going to have it about
Russia and Vladimir Putin but Jamie can
you just give us a little tour the
resort of what done what we know of what
Donald Trump's intentions are with the
world that's outside Russia because we
do want to hear Mary Ann down on that
but the Middle East on China he talked
about China a lot just give us a sense
of what you think the Trump doctrine
might actually be well as I said I think
that the theme to the extent you can
find a thread in the statements and the
new policy choices that have been
focused on or the the personnel is a
more aggressive stance on on the
religious background of terrorists and
the immigration link even today the
Somali from Ohio State the
president-elect and I'm sorry unlike
some other people in this room I
actually take it seriously when the
president-elect speaks to the public
President Obama tweeted and used social
media for eight years there's nothing
new about this the question is what does
he say what are the words that are
chosen and I haven't worked for a
president I took the words pretty
seriously and so when a president speaks
I take it seriously maybe that's a
mistake maybe I should be in the
metaphor business but but um what he
said today is that the Somali didn't
belong in the United States I don't
think we know whether he was born here
or whether he was an immigrant yet or
whether his parents were born here I I
don't know the answer to that New York
Times well so then so then you read the
New York Times I hope you get all your
facts there rather than some of the
other places in any event the point is
is that that will be a theme that will
be a focus of the administration on
China we'll see if he starts a trade war
the president has the power to start a
trade war it won't be a congressional
thing it will be a presidential thing I
think that would be a
extremely ill-advised thing to do but
it's something he promised on that we
haven't seen one of those in that recent
right the new trade Wars become shooting
Wars uh well I would say it a different
way the fact that the United States and
China have found a way to manage their
adversarial relationship is partly a
function of increased trade relations
deeming it less in people's interest to
start a shooting war in the South China
Sea where the current Chinese president
has taken a very aggressive stance and
we'll just have to see what happens but
I do need to veer into the Russia
subject because it is the dominating
subject of of the Trump foreign policy
of the European foreign policy we're
about to have a French president it's
either going to be the feel or Marilla
Pen who is literally regarding da
Vladimir Putin as a friend to be
sanctions should be lifted despite
what's gone on in Syria despite the fact
that Vladimir Putin reached deep inside
the American political system and risked
risk this is the point not what he did
that he would risk a conflict with the
United States by digging deep into our
system and that comes after a big
country they did a small conscious
explains people here you'll talk about
the I'm talking about the healing of an
WikiLeaks and so for those of you who
are Republicans who used to believe and
particularly a Mitt Romney former
associate Mitt Romney regarded and
turned out to be right that Russia was
the biggest threat we faced in 2012 well
I think we face it and what's worse is
that we're not going to have we the
those of us who are concerned about a
Russia and remember what we're talking
about here we're talking about a
president who invited into his office
Bashar Assad who has been working with
Iran working with Hezbollah and has been
responsible for the mass murder of
hundreds of thousands of people and
Vladimir Putin was happy to invite him
in declare him his friend after those
mass murders and coming
and help him win and he's about to win
and that came after mr. Putin arranged
for the invasion of a European country
and the annexation of a piece of that
European country now we're here in
London and the idea that people are not
more outraged by this the idea that
people are shrugging their shoulders
about Vladimir Putin's invasion of
another country which now Donald Trump
for whatever reason and we can speculate
about it believes that working with
Putin is a great thing and that
sanctions should be lifted and his
people removed the support for Ukrainian
defense forces in the in the in the
platform there is going to be a sea
change in the West relationship with
Russia and I would argue and maybe I'll
be all wrong and I'll be happy to be
shown to be wrong that four years from
now they're going to be a lot of unhappy
people that we got into bed with such a
pernicious Russian leader okay thank you
I just want to see if I can see Philip
Bobbitt there and I just want to see if
Philip can hear us Philip you seem as if
you can hear us from doing the little
image I've got there is Philip Bob it
there for Philip it's excluded he's
talking and I can see my little
thumbnail screen but while we're we're
going to still triangle isn't that a fly
we're still going to try and get get
contact with him in reality not just
metaphorically but you've heard a very
trenchant presentation of the case there
from Jamie Rubin marriages Jeff Skilling
Russia and Trump well I hope I can make
an equally trenchant case in completely
the opposite direction
Jamie talked about there being over the
next four years a sea change in
relations with Russia and between the US
and Russia between the west and Russia
generally and I would applaud that I
would say there could be nothing better
than a sea change in Western relations
with Russia led by the United States
if it's under Donald Trump so be it
there were a lot of things that were
said completely wrongly and misleadingly
during the campaign one of them was as
Jamie went into enormous detail
about the cyber hacking of the Democrats
this was never ever ever proved beyond
all reasonable doubt to have come from
the Russians first second do you not
believe that everybody who has the
capability to hack other people is
hacking absolutely as much as they can
by cyber or any other way what through
other peanut the hacking other peels
election campaigns people want the
intelligence they're going to try and
get it by any means it's not if Russia
is doing it's not alone doing it it's
not alone having the capability that's
the first they give another example
recently I know the United States does
have record but they each hold on hold
on I'm talking Marvin we know Russia and
the United States has a record in
intervening in other elections but can
you think of a recent example where they
have hacked into the databases of
democratic parties and published the the
hacked contents is there another thing
comparable to what WikiLeaks did in this
area has done before several times
that's just it
well I mean I don't I don't know that
there needs to be a precedent we just
said others are doing yet know what at
what I'm arguing is that other people
are going to be trying to find
intelligence on other people's election
campaigns especially where those
campaigns are so closely fought as the
one in the United States and where the
outcome is so important for everybody
around the world obviously everybody is
going to be hacking if they then choose
to publish it well you know why not I
mean that doesn't seem to me to be any
different order of interfering in this
is not interfering in other people's
elections it's really it's it's trying
to figure out what is going on
we've seen in in the past we've seen the
Americans and Western countries
generally interfering in elections in
eastern formerly Eastern Bloc countries
like including Ukraine and including
Georgia where we send envoy's and we
send we
NGOs working on the side of opposition
politicians now that is absolutely fine
but you can't say it's fine for us to be
doing that and it's not fine for other
people that we maybe don't see
eye-to-eye with to be doing that that is
a complete double standard okay but I
mean ticket did you donate to annex not
you because we know about the idea that
people take a very dim view of the idea
that Donald Trump could rebuild restart
relations with Russia and he's I think
been misleadingly presented as admiring
Putin thinking Putin's a jolly good
thing thinking Russia is a wonderful
place he does not say that he said that
he admired it he said he admired a
porting as a national leader who stood
up for his country and represented the
national interest and he was saying that
to contrast him for electoral reasons
with President Obama right or wrong that
is the context in which he said it and I
think that Putin and Trump who says he
can he says that he thinks he can do
business with Putin that is exactly what
an American president ought to be
setting out to do depends which means my
business I suppose the debate let's hear
from an emperor I mean I hardly know
where to begin
so so
I mean first of all the the pattern of
Russian interference in the American
election is one that is very familiar to
me
I've watched elections in Ukraine in
Poland in other parts of Central Europe
where there's been very open very clear
it wasn't always hacked material
sometimes it was tapes sometimes it was
other things where they've been Russian
Secret Service interventions and
election campaigns and so this is
absolutely fit into a pattern that was
recognizable it's not something the
United States does I'm not aware of any
similar American involvement at all or
and really anybody else and I'm also I
also don't believe that the I just come
back on that marriage marry you wait
marry a second ago you were asked
exactly this question you couldn't
answer it have you thought of an answer
now I was told that there was a
distinction between publishing the
findings and not publishing the findings
my argument was everybody is doing
better no no no Mary I'm not talking
about hacking I'm talking about
intervening in an election campaign
using targeted hacked material in order
to do that that is not what Russia was
doing in this election OSHA did not
interfere in the American election are
you sure can okay let's let's move on
the point about Trump is that and I
should think the most important point
about him is really not the point about
Russia um he has been a longtime admirer
of Putin he's repeatedly said he admires
him going back many many years not just
in the last two years following the
invasion of Ukraine in 2014 he said he
it complimented him for doing this on
television I've seen the clip of it it
exists you can go and find it so so
let's just put that to one side the more
important point about Trump is what kind
of a leader of the Western alliance is
he going to be this is somebody who
since the first time I know of him doing
it maybe he did it before was in 2000 he
began denigrating and undermining the
NATO alliance and not just because it's
you know he often speaks about being it
very expensive but he's gone quite a bit
farther than that in some of his
statements it's not just that he wants
NATO members to pay up he has said why
should we be involved in European Wars
what is it what is our interest there
he's been very clear that he's not
interested
he has no emotion
or or political or moral sense of
attachment to Europe and he said by the
way the same thing about Japan and South
Korea I just spoke this afternoon to a
Japanese journalist who says you know
there's an enormous amount of concern in
Japan because America is its only
security umbrella is this going to
continue we don't know
you know the signals have been very
mixed and very complicated so what my
concern about Trump is that he is he
doesn't see himself he doesn't he
doesn't see himself as a leader of a
group of democratic countries and he
doesn't seem to understand the benefit
of alliances you know that the United
States benefits not just it's not just
the u.s. spending money to put troops
places it's also the leader of a you
know of a group of countries which get
which which have created a political and
legal trade and economic and political
order which has been hugely beneficial
to the United States to this country and
to all of Europe and he doesn't believe
in that he doesn't care about it
good moment to GUP thank you okay my
fingers are crossed as I asked if Philip
Bobbitt can hear us I'm looking
confidently as I can hear you excellent
and we can hear you so a round of
applause I just want you to pick up
because that you're somebody who served
administration's of both parties just
pick up that question that Anne
Applebaum ended there with which is what
kind of Western alliance would he lead
how would he lead the Western alliance
and just your perspective I think that I
think the answer is we don't know we
don't really know what sort of alliance
leader he would be all the reservations
that an expressed I have I would have
thought that in the campaign the highest
priority of someone running for
president would be to increase the
expectation of solidarity across the
Alliance Trump didn't do that
indeed as an suggested he did just the
opposite he but whether this will
persist as a policy I don't think we
really know thank you
we gain Stacey's quick reference a
feeling then we're going to do tonight
can I jump in on the Russia thing as
well just for a second off to Stacey
well I'm keen to get the audience in
Steve so what we'll do is we'll get the
audience and I'll come back to you make
sure you get to say all that yes I say
very quickly on the NATO issue I've
spoken with one of the advisors that's
been talking to him about NATO and what
they've really spoken about is reform of
NATO this is something that even then
everybody within the Alliance has been
speaking about for several years but
they've said you know the the remit of
the NATO alliances as a peacekeeping
force and so if we're going to be having
a warm a war force then we need to look
at maybe possible two different strains
to that and so I think that what you
would see is moving forward in the
policies with that is how is it going to
perform what's it going to look like is
it going to stay as is one entity or is
it going to have a separate one attached
to it thank you
I not said for us to bite on let's take
some questions I'm going to bring them
back here to this panel people with
microphones you do have somebody there
already so we'll go with that first hold
on and I want to make sure the
microphones here second as you know I
always insist on the gender balance I
would quite like if we had one of our
female questioners there we are I
haven't got the trump memo yet so I take
women seriously and make sure we hear
from them so let's hear from the
question number one yeah I say very
quick question regarding the Supreme
Court which hasn't come up yet who and
what kind of justice do the panel expect
to replace Scalia and also second side
point is this the first campaign when
we've all wanted the winning candidate
to break all his election promises good
thank you
there's somebody here I hope yep hi I'm
Jamie from Vanity Fair
Vanity Fair fans have been following
they've been close to you on Twitter and
they've been submitting the questions
the following question was a bit about
Olivia Rutan she asks how long will it
take society to and do the ills that
Trump is already committed thank you did
she say what those a lilz are no so we
can fill in the blank
let's see gentlemen here with the red
sweater on and then we'll part and then
we'll ask him to pass the microphone to
you yeah shouldn't Europe pay its way in
NATO okay applause for that
and could you pass the microphone just
along today yes Frankie yeah I think we
cannot we cannot hide from the are were
in this election because this was it was
the white vote that got
trumping and I'm surprised not a single
Hispanic speaker in the group so I have
a question about that and is what are
the Trump supporters going to do when
the extreme ride is racist and
xenophobic not as the extreme lifts are
going are attacking people for being
foreigners are all you Trump supporters
who claim not to be racist going to do
something about it
or are you going to keep your hands
cross and the other question the other
thing is that's enough I think digging
climate change
okay climate change I'll make sure we
talk about it thank you that I'm just
trying to sweep it move things along
somebody's waving at me frantically over
here yes this will be the last one in
this round I'm going to take out this
don't worry and people up there yeah hi
I'm Mexican I don't have horns I did not
come here illegally but I do have a very
large top trump pinata at home yeah and
I want to share with you what happened
to my seven-year-old son at one of
London's top schools if I should if I
should say that he's seven years old and
one of his classmates told him very
recently I am a trump supporter all
Mexicans are terrorists except for you
so I think you know he makes metaphors
whatever offense but I think the point
here is that whether or not we have the
luxury of taking Trump seriously we
cannot sidestep the fact that he won
this election by mobilizing people
around dehumanizing others and I think
and I and I want to ask is this the
world that we want our children to grow
up in and I do put that question to the
Trump supporters thank you thank you
okay with those two last questions I'm
going to come round over we're going to
do another round those two last
questions I think do belong together and
why don't we put them straight to you
Ted Malik the the question the
questioner suggests that from one even
if it was in his program he won by
mobilizing some of this racially charged
hostility and again the lady here said
what a trump supporters going to do with
the fact that that was a big part of his
support so I was on CNN a month or so
before the election on Becky Anderson
show and she asked me the question in
all seriousness don't you think the rest
of the world should vote for the
American president and I looked at her
and I read back her question to her does
it make any sense at all that the rest
of the world would vote in the American
election so the Americans have voted
they've made their decision I mean they
won through the electoral college
that's not addressing this question this
question wasn't was not about whether
the rest of us ever vote the question
was and racist feeling was mobilized
said the questioner in this election
victory what do Trump supporters do with
the fact as they argue that a lot of
this racial resentment was stirred and
played a part in Trump's victory is
there a jobless or repairing to be done
azurite I think that you do need as he
said in his victory night's speech to
bring the country together to heal the
divides to go forward to bring diversity
into the cabinet into the government I
mean the the I mean I guess an impartial
answer the the oddity might be that a
higher percentage of Mexicans and blacks
voted for Donald Trump then voted for
Romney or McCain 29% of Latino voters
she's joking
and it's they showed their car I just
want to call up Steve Hilton if I can
and taking the risk of losing the line
to Phillip Bobbitt I hope not but Steve
and climate change came up here it
didn't come up in the four and a half
hours of televised debate but you
you famously advised David Cameron when
he was in his vote blue go green
period you took climate change seriously
the candidate you've been advocating for
says that climate changes are hoax
perpetrated by the Chinese and I wonder
how you square that with your earlier
advocacy of a position on climate change
the simple answer is that I've never
acquainted being Green with climate
change and so the action that that I
argue very strongly for in in the period
running up to the 2010 election and
subsequently was actually not not
focused mainly on climate change but
more on conservation and the alarm that
we should have of a species lost
biodiversity and so on I think that
what's the problem with climate change
and the reasons that actually despite
the you know I just use the word
obsession with climate change on in
certain parts of the left in America is
that actually it's it's an agenda that's
been captured by big business it's not
really about being green or
environmental at all actually what it's
really about now is taxpayer subsidy to
big businesses to support a particular
economic response isn't it's not really
about being green at all so I've never
seen being green as the same as taking
climate change circular see I mean
actually more of a skeptic than many
people assumed from my advocacy of the
green agenda okay thank you and Stacy
Lee I want you to take out the very
first question about who you expect or
perhaps who you think should be
nominated to this vacant seat on the
Supreme Court tremendously important for
American law and culture etc those
decisions that a judge can make and
perhaps you want to address I think this
point about race that's come up I think
just on the Supreme Court the type of
justices that we're looking at or
somebody who's going to be more of a
constitutionalist I'm that's what you've
kind of heard him talking about you have
her chunk talked about he would appoint
pro-life judges and I know this has
since shivers down a lot of people's
spines but if you look at people like
Ted Cruz who will not be appointed to
the Supreme Court and he specifically
said that just the other day to somebody
but saying
it encouraging well maybe for you I'm
but I think it's people who respect the
law and the law is the law and that they
will they will look at it that way
they're not going to go out and seek to
overturn anything um but people who will
actually be seen as a strict
constitutional this is the type of
justices that he'll be looking at I'm
but I do want to just what I hope so and
I and I disagree with them and and I
think that's I think that's funny
because I'm not sure everyone heard it
why don't we bring the microphone to the
rather well-known questioner well it's
very very I'm sorry but I'm a bit of a
busybody I've just come from my show I'm
very you know adrenaline end up and I'm
listening to this conversation I think
several things have to be made clear one
we clearly live in a post truth society
the idea that green is not the same as
climate change and conversation is
bananas the idea the idea that that
Vladimir Putin somehow is the great
defender of all the values that we
believe in I mean does anybody has
anybody asked what Vladimir Putin has
done in Syria Mary really honestly
seriously is that the kind of world that
we want look at area right now one more
one more and then we give amendment of
the united states you say a strict
constitutionalist right I'm a journalist
I believe in free speech is my
guaranteed right as a journalist working
for an American Society the President of
the United States elect made his first
tweet threatening the media talking
about inciting protests that's the first
one and then he's just come out and
talked about protests and flag burning
so which part of the Constitution it's
like these are legitimate questions it's
his freedom of speech to say those
things as well and I think you know I I
totally disagree with him about the flag
burning a comment that he made and I
he's received a lot of criticism about
that I'm but as far as the issues
bringing up to speed this was a tweet he
said there was an issue yes there is an
issue with a university in New Hampshire
I believe that I'm there the flag was
taken down to have
mass after the election I'm and people
were protesting and somebody pulled it
down and burnt it and it was being
covered and he tweeted and he said those
people should perhaps lose their
citizenship well actually well Hillary
Clinton was I believe a signatory to a
bill the flag burning the building it
gave $100,000 fine in a year in prison
do I know you again we've stayed you off
you wanted to make a quick point about
the race claim that was not and I just
want to hear your response that there's
another well-known Trump supporter here
I also want to put it to him so let's
just get back on to the question I think
it's I think it's really important to
address this race issue but this is
something that has been boiling for the
last eight years I've seen the divisions
happening in our society that we haven't
had in the past and I think one as far
as with the election as far as everybody
saying what was only the whites who came
out and it was a white supremacist
movement that came and voted Trump and
that's incorrect what voted Trump in was
Obama voters who voted for him in 2008
in 2012
and Michigan and Pennsylvania Hillary
Clinton was unable to motivate those
voters and get them out to the polls so
but I just I think it's important to
address the race issue because one of
the things that we do need is leadership
and we haven't had that over the eight
years we've had somebody the president
coming out and actually placing blame
instead of actually being a leader and
saying let's pull people together to
talk about this but somebody who has led
on it is nikki Haley who's now employed
as as you an ambassador who when there
was the shooting in the South Carolina
Church she was actually able to bring
her communities together and they didn't
have rioting like they did in the other
places like in Missouri were you just
saying a minute ago you thought Barack
Obama didn't try to bring people
everybody said assign blame I think he
did because when he came out he would
automatically place blame on to the
police officers or he would
automatically i'm sympathized with with
while he did you can look at his
comments but as the president of united
states he should actually be saying we
clearly have a problem and so what we
need to do is bring the leaders of our
communities together and we i as the
president of united states need to sit
everybody down and come up with a
solution and find out why this is
happening
nobody has asked the why question nobody
has said what's the root cause of this
okay and the
so much ground to cover I recognize it
since we've had Christiane Amanpour from
the sea from CNN
Charlie wolf is a regular broadcaster on
American TV networks and did has been a
supporter of Donald Trump just tell us
how you deal with this thing that people
said here which is Trump supporters need
to acknowledge the fact that some of the
mobilizing energy in this campaign was
hostile to different racial minorities
and you know that the Ku Klux Klan and
David Duke endorsed from very warm in
their endorsement Donald Trump you as
somebody who backs songs from how do you
deal with that
sorry wolf it was said when Reagan was
backed by someone who was one of these
white supremacist groups at the time
Reagan said well actually he's endorsing
my plan not I'm endorsing his plan and
that's how I think it was the other day
with the the chap in Washington DC was
endorsing Trump and Trump's plan so
Trump isn't endorsing his you know I
think most Americans the vast majority
of Americans take race relations very
seriously
and it has disturbed me that in the last
eight years we have seen this sort of
split between the black and the white
communities and it's under a black
president and I don't fully know why I
don't know why groups like black lives
matter have been invited to the White
House that have only caused problems to
the black community not helped them at
all and yes unfortunately mr. Obama has
made many many times has opened his
mouth before the brain was engaged in
putting forward things that weren't true
professor Gates being one I have a son
if I had a son he'd look like Trayvon
getting involved in things where he
shouldn't have been and I would also
point out sorry Charlie how is that
racially divisive to say if I had a son
he would have looked like Trayvon
because he was taking a side between the
police and in the event before we knew
what was going on that was the problem
there he what no a as nothing no I
all right couldn't complete your punch I
just wanted one important point I wanted
to put towards Jaime he gave a very very
good explanation of Syria and what's
going on there but let me ask who was
the president it hasn't been Donald
Trump it's been mr. Obama and it's mr.
Obama who said a red wine that he didn't
back up now I think with mr. Trump Trump
at least Trump at least respects power
and I think people have power respect
power back
I see someone like Trump able to
negotiate better than mr. Obama will
because unlike a senator who will just
fly down like he did for Iran Trump will
expect something in return and I think
that's one of the reasons why I have
more faith in him than I do mr. Obama
okay the second half of the Amanpour
Reuben tag team is keen is keen to break
in here so it's very briefing and I want
to put something Emily you are correct
President Obama's decision not to follow
through on the red line is part of the
reason that Syria has collapsed into the
situation it's in okay that's true
I don't think you can dispute that but
that that's a failure to act what we're
talking about here and the reason why I
am so and you can see I'm not the only
one concerned about mr. Putin is because
he has acted he has returned Russia to
the Middle East where they've never been
for the last I don't know 30 years and
he's been responsible to have their
airplanes working with the Syrian
airplanes to bomb civilians and destroy
them and the president-elect has not
found it in his interest to even mention
that and has frankly said that he thinks
Putin is doing a pretty good job in
Syria when mr. Putin hasn't struck Isis
there's this big myth that the Russians
are in in in Syria much Isis and that's
what what a president-elect Trump has
blessed but all they've really done is
destroy the opposition which is why
Aleppo will fall in the next couple of
days and mr. Assad responsible for mass
murder we're talking about intelligence
agencies recording the names of the
victims so they am taking pictures of
each one so they can get credit for
killing 50,000 not just 45,000 that's
the society that mr. Putin wants to
bless and see victorious along with the
Iranian leadership along with Hezbollah
and that's who mr. Trump wants to work
closely with without referring to all
those things that's my problem we all
want to deal with the Russians but if
you're going to forget their invasion of
Ukraine if you're going to forget what
they did in Syria
if you're going to forget their
interference and no one has ever done it
where they've published the information
okay there's a big difference
the NGOs in Georgia are openly
supporting democracy there's no hidden
secret plan to remove information and
publish it that's the difference
President Obama stand up to this evil
tyrant not very well not very well okay
but mister but mister Obama at least had
the dignity the dignity to say that we
the countries don't invade small
countries and impose sanctions and mr.
Trump wants to lift them that's my
problem okay
let's um hear from
marry there is so many questions that
are addressed to you so I'm just going
to scoop up one last little more and
then it's coming to you but an apple and
the question was put shouldn't Europe
pay its way in Nate absolutely
absolutely I am very much in favor of a
reinvigoration of NATO I think that I'm
in favor of by the way I'm very much in
favor of an you contribution to NATO
I want Europe to be aware of what's
happening not only on its borders but
inside its own country but that is not
that is not what Trump has said that is
not that that is not the end of what he
said he is he has been been a much his
criticism of the alliance is much deeper
it's it's a it's a trading relationship
it's you know will help them if they do
X or Y for us you know it's we don't
really need to be involved in these wars
it's there he has never said anything
that I have been able to find her that I
have heard which indicates any sense of
responsibility for this international
system that has been created that has
served America and that has served
Europe and has served others over the
last 50 years since the war he has no
interest in it he's willing to destroy
it he's not bothered by it so John
absolutely we should reinforce NATO
filippov it gone let me just one point
on this subject it's true that the
conventional forces of NATO of a crucial
part of our cooperation that's also true
the Europeans don't do enough but the
most vital link is the nuclear link to
the ice States deterrent it is extended
deterrence not our conventional forces
that prevented Europe from being taken
over for decades and it also by the way
defended other powers from acquiring
their own nuclear weapons because they
could rely on us now whatever Donald
Trump may may not feel about the
contributions to to the budgets of these
various members if he calls into
question American nuclear deterrents for
the members of NATO then I think he has
shattered the alliance okay he has
called into question nuclear deterrence
for a nation all right it's time for
marriage Jessica to come back on so many
of these ones
briefly like to address the NATO
question because I think I'm probably
not such a gigantic fan of NATO as
either an apple bomb or Philip Bobbitt
because I tend to think that its
usefulness really expired at the end of
the Cold War and that its continued
existence is one of the biggest sources
of insecurity across Europe today and I
think that Donald Trump is entirely he
has a degree of right on his side in at
least questioning it and I also think
that yes if if there's going to be a
more transactional attitude from the
United States to European defence then
this is the opportunity that Europe has
been looking for and has either copped
out of or has been discouraged from by
previous American administrations to
organize its own defense and I think one
of the tragedies here is that with
brexit that Britain will be leaving the
European Union and so the prospect of a
coordinated strong European defense is
actually less than it would have been
before so that's the that's the NATO
question now as an celebre with that I
don't know where to begin on on the
other questions certainly brief use
again because we I want to gather to two
points yeah and on the question of Trump
being an admirer of Putin Putin's values
post-soviet Russia that is absolutely
not true when when Trump has talked
about Russia
he has actually disclaimed any
admiration either for values or for how
the Russian society is organized what he
says is very similar actually to what
Margaret Thatcher said said about
Gorbachev this is a man I can do
business with following up
we disagree fundamentally on many issues
is what Margaret Thatcher said
nonetheless I think that we can do this
and she was vindicated and I think that
Trump may also be vindicated in the same
way you would be your division in a
different category morally than
Gorbachev than you
in the sense of inferior or superior
well maybe maybe you've answered my
question maybe you've answered my
question do you have one more thing you
were going to say sit breathe as you
Canada me have not skated more people I
wanted to talk about Syria because I
think the idea that that Obama didn't
apparently honor his red line over
chemical use of chemical weapons in
Syria that is a complete
misinterpretation misconception Obama
explained a lot of in his Atlantic
magazine interview where he said that
there were times when when it was wiser
not to do things and more difficult not
to do things than actually to do them
and I think that if you'd seen the
United States intervening in Syria in
that active way then you could be an
even worse mess than we're in at the
moment okay thank so I'd I'd like to say
that Russia Russia is actually we mean
we may like it we may not like it Russia
is the only outside interventionist in
Syria which is there legally according
to the United Nations because it was
invited in by Assad it's a lie now as I
say you may like it you may not like it
and I would also ask the question do you
think it's more humanitarian for the
West to be arming and training rebels
who have no hope of winning and
prolonging the conflict over Aleppo
prolonging the number of casualties or
is it actually more humane to let
somebody win and have talks and have a
bargaining session about a post-war
settlement in Syria okay I asked that
most of it what I'm going to say
generally is that we are here to discuss
focus on Trump we've got into a very big
discussion about Russia and Syria which
I understand given the position but
let's try and focus back on our title
Trump tragedy microphone number for that
you've got a question there and we're
going to try and get voices all around
the room and then we'll go to number
three but
hi I'm Elise I'm also a busybody and
I've just come from watching Christians
show
for those on the panel that support
Trump can we all in this room have a
pledge that you'll be back here in four
and again in eight years defending the
history of President Trump please okay
it's over there microphone number three
and if we could have a microphone over
here because there's a couple of people
are very eager yeah number three a
question mainly to Steve um you made a
comment that intrigued me how can you
call his hate speech on Twitter not a
real problem when it's normalized hate
speech and lead people some people I'm
not saying all of his supporters but to
think that hatred is normal and it has
led people you know fearing for their
security safety and it has led to
attacks thank you okay have we got a
microphone over here there's a lady you
had a hand up here and then the judge
will go to the gentleman lady first yeah
good evening this question is for the
panel but also for Philip Bobbitt I'd
like to ask how the business interests
of Trump are in direct conflict with the
constitutional the Constitution of the
United States and how this impacts the
vote of the electoral college Oh
interesting and I'm Philip babadook also
an expert on constitutional law so we'll
put that in and the gentleman in front
await you patiently yep thank you mr.
Rubin I'd like to ask you how can you
mention Donald Trump thinking of
removing sanctions when Obama a hundred
and fifty billion dollars to the number
one purveyor of terrorism in the world
it's ridiculous you should be ashamed of
mentioning that are you mentioning it
wrong yes of course didn't say it so I'm
aren't we still out of money we start
the plane we saw the hostages
there's nobody here we didn't see that
did everybody see that second miss
Applebaum every single and the question
is how can he possibly talk about it
when there's a hundred and fifty billion
dollars going to again here to your
second question miss Applebaum every
single one of the illegal immigrants is
illegal the job of the President of the
United States is to keep the law period
try and explain that in three get the
professional three no it's very short
question well I want to go to the lady
there with a microphone
the lady there with her hand up if you
can stand up no we got enough gum we got
two is enough let's hear from the lady
there if you can see me you need to keep
your hand up otherwise they don't know
to you Gary I'll keep your hand up yeah
and you're gonna be the last one in this
round so sorry for people who didn't
manage to get a go yeah yeah um this is
for Anne and Jamie and Jonathan for
yourself where would I come from that's
actually different Perth hello okay you
weren't the person had in mind but
nevertheless okay we'll hear from you
and then we'll hear from you
yeah um given that there's so much
dissension amongst the panel about
what's truth and what isn't coming out
of Donald Trump's mouth in terms of
journalists covering Donald Trump now
and for the next four years I know Jamie
your wife has spoken very eloquently
about this recently but for Jonathan for
you and for Anne and whomever else wants
to
how did journalists Trump cover Trump
given the new state of play that we're
in he says and this will be the last one
here the lady's been waiting yeah um I
was just wondering how the panel think
that Trump will affect Cuban US
relations thank you okay very specific
thank you I'm sorry people I couldn't
get to we are almost running out of time
so we're going to pieces to all of the
panel and are people joining us via
videolink
this is going to be your last sort of go
so this is time to make closing remarks
really why don't we hear from you
Phillip Bobbitt if you can still hear us
this really specific question about this
so the Trump's business interest and if
you could unpack for us what the charge
against Tim is in terms of the
Constitution and how this might affect
the electoral college and it's a bit
arcane but I think it's worth explaining
so could you just talk walk us through
that Oh
oh that's such a shame
slight gloating look on Steve Hilton
face I think no I think he's floating
maybe he's lost his mic friends well
okay well is there anyone here who could
have done the pond about on monuments
and the Electoral College and camp and
Beyond so sorry to fill it bother enough
of them so I am NOT a constitutional
lawyer but there is a clause in the
Constitution that says a president
cannot accept emoluments from foreign
sources and this so essentially any kind
of payment that comes to Donald Trump
through his company that comes from
abroad theoretically can be construed as
a bribe or as an attempt to influence
the president knighted States one way or
the another would take an act of
Congress by the way to prove that a
moment okay and that's not going to
happen
it's a non-issue so I'm sorry that
Philip Bobbitt can't be more more
precise than I can I think there's
actually a deeper and broader issue and
I was trying to find a place to bring
this up before which is you know whether
or not its constitutional there is if
there is a profound moral problem with
the the fact that Trump has not revealed
his income taxes we don't know who owns
his companies I am told I do not have
proof I mean you'll begin this you know
it supposed true Society but I would
like to say you know the here I don't
know I don't have the proof I'm not
going to claim something I don't know I
I have been told that there is for
example massive Russian investment in
his buildings in the United States that
many of the apartments there have come
on come on
you could do better I think you can do
better Deutsche Bank his son has said so
son you don't believe his son Jamie T
Washington's have invested in some of
his properties sorry that's it sorry
Russians have invested in some of his
properties so huh okay everyone else
that's what I just said but Ted you cook
good all I said that's all that's why
you said so all I'm saying is he is
somebody who is who invested in the
Clinton Foundation doesn't matter
anymore it doesn't matter any no she's
not president we noticed she's not but
so sorry I'm sorry this is this is going
to be an issue that is going to be on
the front pages every single day until
he either
until he either makes his makes his
companies transparent puts his companies
into a blind trust not run by his
children run by somebody completely
different cuts himself off totally so
that he can prove that he is not being
influenced by people who invest in his
companies I don't I don't know if he's
going to do that I've so far seen no
signs of it but this will be an issue
every single day of that for the next
four years he did announce that he
started the legal paperwork in December
15th I think gray now he's announced it
he still hasn't said what that means he
hasn't he hasn't indicated that his
children won't be involved
he hasn't cut himself off from his
companies yet when he does it we can
talk about that but he has not done it
thankee married you just see well how
should journalists cover Donald Trump I
think they should cover Donald Trump
exactly the same way they cover
everybody else I mean I don't see that
there that there is an issue here you
report what people say if you're a
commentator you can say you disapprove
you don't believe it or you think it's
absolutely wonderful and if you really
want what if he lies we haven't had a
president who aggressively lies every
day on Twitter before we have crazy
I didn't hear Kevin we didn't hear Ted
Malik's response well we've had a
president that has lied every day on
Twitter for eight years so the Obamas
ride every day absolutely and you can go
in the great favorite in London can you
give an example of a lie that he's told
out he came over here and tried to get
people to vote again Brett he said he
lied that's a little lie that's not a
lie that's a nom I mean that isn't I
mean urging people to vote one way on
breaks it may be unwise it wasn't untrue
it wasn't untrue well yeah you offered
an opinion how is that I don't know how
that could be untrue he's just saying
this is what I think this is advice okay
Jamie do you want to respond to how
journalists should cover how journalists
should come out I'm going to answer it
in a slightly different way as I think
people will be interested not that the
Democrats are very important anymore the
Clinton administration is is never gonna
be you don't have to worry about the
Clinton Foundation you don't have to
worry about all the stuff related to
Hillary but there are some Democrats
left a few in the House a few in the
Senate in the minority and I think there
is going to be a real challenge to
figure out how to deal with a president
of the kind that we've mentioned and so
I'm going to make a suggestion which I'm
going to try to hold to by the time that
Donald Trump becomes president and I'm
going to give myself another month and a
half to focus only on policy it's going
to be the hardest thing in the world to
do but I think the Democrats would be
wise to disagree as aggressively as they
see necessary and focus on the policy
they disagree with and put aside I was
quite impressed with the piece from an
Italian during the Berlusconi era who
said that the opposition lost a lot of
value by spending all their time talking
about Berlusconi's individually I think
Donald Trump's behavior so far is far in
excess of Berlusconi so I'm going to
enjoy for another month saying what I
really believe for example that he lied
to the American people yesterday about
the votes and then used a McCarthyite
tactic to demand that the
side proved that what he said isn't true
that's when Joe McCarthy had his list of
45 communists in the State Department
and then he asked them to prove it's not
true after he invented the 45 okay so so
and just one point on Iran I know you
don't like the agreement but some people
like the agreement the Congress didn't
stop it they weren't able to so far it's
the Iran agreement has been pretty
successful or honest okay let me just
let me just get my point out so far they
have limited their enrichment of uranium
which was the purpose of it and 150
billion all right all right we did here
we did here we have we heard you before
it's a moot point anyway I'll make you a
side bet that Donald Trump keeps the
bulk of the Iran agreement Oh better
than our I got a side bet Mary agrees Oh
anyway I think illegal immigration is
illegal okay we're here we must have a
lot of us
justjust let's close up a few of these
points just on the question of their I
could ask about the Iran deal and also
there was somebody else also about the
Cuban deal to what extent do you think
Obama is gonna run Trump is going to row
back those Obama deals and agreements
why just for just a drama if you look at
the e so-called gettysburg address where
he prompts 228 things he's going to do
all 28 of those things Donald Trump is
not a politician now he's elected
politician he's a builder he's going to
do everything he said he would do
because he delivers on what he says he
will do and one of those will be
actually to rollback regulation but it
certainly will be as he said in the
Cuban instance to roll back some of what
Obama started some of what some of what
so we're not going to go back to where
we were in terms of Cuban US relations
well we'll see where we go it depends
what Cuba's willing to do itself Mary
this is a probably the one point on
which the pair of us disagree I think
Cuba is the perfect opportunity for
President Trump I think it's going to
play to all his strengths and he may
verbally roll back a little bit but I
think the temptation to go into league
with Cuba to him for the u.s. under
President Trump to invest in Cuba
enormous ly to try and bring it up to
standard Cuba is the perfect example and
I think President Trump will be the
perfect head of the US state to do it
and Stacey iliad I'm going to let you
close out with this thought unless we
can still hit Steve Hilton able to hear
us yes
Steve Steve builders but can we hear him
right can we hear him that's the
question Steve can be here I can hear
you good good good okay so very quickly
Steve you were asked about the various
hate speech that the questioner said the
president-elect is guilty of on Twitter
and you were asked for somebody's been
supporting him specifically the question
was directed to you how can you defend
it just as brief as you can because we
in our last 90 seconds yes okay I think
that question was in response the
discussion at Jamie Reis about the
accusations of voting irregularities and
they exchanged CNN now you may say that
what he said about Melissa people voting
illegally was crazy or laughable or
wrong but it's not hate speech and I
think that the real point here on
Trump's behavior is that it would be
great if we could have a president who
was both dignified and effective but
actually what we've seen over the last
eight years
and likely to see in the next four or
eight years is that I'm afraid that's
not an offer we've had a president in
Obama who's been extremely dignified
conducted and soft beautifully uses
words beautifully but I'm afraid and in
terms of the economy at home has not
been effective he's delivered stagnation
and internationally his projected
weakness abroad including encouraging
the adventurism of Putin and looking
forward I think given the state of the
US economy and people's living standards
and the state of the world and the
threats we face from terrorism and
elsewhere I fear that we're going to
have to take effectiveness over a
dignified president and I think that's
the right choice to make thank you very
concise at closing last word to you
Stacy him I'm I just want to go back a
little bit about the comments about
Trump on Twitter and what it's actually
normalized I am I think we do have to
take what he says on Twitter seriously
he is the president in nine states and
what he wrote president-elect and when
he becomes president
that is going to have influence whether
it's on markets whether it's on trade
whether it's on foreign relations and I
think that that's something that he will
have to learn and unfortunately I don't
like my president being an apprentice in
the job but I think that he will see the
realities that he's facing and everybody
who's come into the presidency
nobody's been president before unless
you've come in on a second term they're
faced with realities they see how
difficult it is for him to deliver on
all 28 things I don't think that's going
to be possible when he sees how
difficult that comes okay well thank you
for that closing word and thanks to all
of you for really engaged in spirited
debate ah
are we back this is going to be the
closing word
you've got a big following here closing
words you fill it bobbing because you've
got a very big director following here
well I really apologize for all my
technical incompetence I think that
Jamie Rubin really said much of what I
would say we have a system of checks and
balances that system depends most
heavily on the Congress not on the
president but you will have substantial
majorities in the house and in the
Senate behind a program that I think
Donald Trump will eventually endorse so
I would expect to see real challenges
for the Democratic Party to keep our our
eyes on on a constitutional in
programmatic basis and to leave some of
the things about Donald Trump which if I
must confess really irritated me and
turned me off to put those to one side
if we don't organize that way then I'm
afraid the public will decide that we're
just as hopeless as as the Republicans
are with that closing word thank you
very much for that and
I was going to take two last things
first I was going to take up the
question a successor suggestion that we
all gather here again in four years time
they also suggested eight years but
let's wait and see for that but I think
we'll all agree to that and lastly I
think you're just going to want to join
me in thanking this terrific aliy
engaged in spiritual panel and Applebaum
James Rubin Safety Hilliard marriage
registry technology see Phil turn and
fill it Bobbitt thank you all very much
thank you
[Music]